Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
« To be or not to be,
that is the question. »
Hamlet, Acte 3, scène 1.
Comme c’est sûr que je ne jouerai pas
ce rôle - car je suis trop vieux -
cet immense rôle d’Hamlet,
je profite d’être devant vous
pour pouvoir déclamer du Shakespeare.
C'est mon rêve.
Il y a une petite controverse
sur cette célèbre réplique.
Un éminent spécialiste shakespearien
de l’Université de Philadelphie
dit que la virgule est mal placée :
pour lui, elle est après le « not ».
Donc ça fait : « To be or not,
to be that is the question. »
Et du coup, « To be or not », virgule,
« to be that is the question ».
Évidemment, ça change le sens :
plus une interrogation,
mais une affirmation :
« To be that is the question. »
Mais comme le texte shakespearien
n’est pas une bible
parce qu’il a été édité longtemps après
sa mort à partir de manuscrits épars,
on ne saura jamais.
Mais en tout cas, à quelque
endroit qu’on place la virgule,
Hamlet pose la question fondamentale,
une question fondamentale
qui est à l’œuvre dans nos existences,
plus particulièrement peut-être
dans les vôtres, en tant qu’étudiants,
c’est celle de notre rapport au monde
et à sa corruption.
Hamlet vit dans un monde où le meurtrier
présumé de son père couche avec sa mère.
« Something is rotten
in the state of Denmark. »
Acte 1, scène 4, Hamlet.
« Il y a quelque chose de pourri
au royaume du Danemark. »
Je vous l’ai dit, moi, vous me donnez
un plateau, je récite du Shakespeare.
En janvier 21, cette année,
il y a eu malheureusement
dans ma ville, à Lyon,
plusieurs tentatives
de suicides d’étudiants
Et mon premier réflexe,
un peu dérisoire, mais spontané,
a été de proposer via les réseaux sociaux,
d’être disponible pour aller boire un
café, discuter, faire un brin de causette.
Le truc m’a un peu dépassé
car ça a été repris
par la presse, par le maire de Lyon.
J’ai eu plus de 300 réponses.
J’ai compris l’ampleur de l’impact négatif
de la crise du Covid sur les étudiants.
Les études, c’est un moment
où ce qu’on fait en dehors des cours
est aussi important que ce qu’on fait
pendant les cours.
C’est un âge où, normalement,
on devrait dire et faire des conneries,
politiser, discuter, faire du sport,
sortir, boire, baiser, rigoler.
Et là, j’ai vu des gens désespérés.
Des fois, j’étais la première personne
qui leur parlait en direct,
face à face, depuis trois mois.
Ces rencontres ont été
extrêmement riches pour moi.
À part le fait, évidemment, qu’à
force de prendre dix cafés par jour,
j’étais complètement speedé,
et que j’ai pris cinq kilos
parce que c’est tombé en janvier, février.
Comme les bars étaient fermés,
nous allions dans les boulangeries.
A Lyon, à ce moment-là, elles font
des bugnes, des beignets excellents.
J’étais avec l’étudiant, l’étudiante :
« Tu n’as pas le moral. On va prendre
100, 200, 300 grammes de bugnes. »
Cinq kilos ! Si on enlève ça,
ça a été extrêmement enrichissant
et ça m’a permis de formuler
une sorte de discours de circonstance.
La première chose qu’il faut énoncer
sérieusement et clairement,
c’est : « C’est la merde »,
il faut le dire, Il ne faut pas le nier.
Les gens qui relativisent la situation
des étudiants, je les trouve crétins.
Il n’y a pas de hiérarchie à avoir,
on peut toujours trouver pire que soi,
mais la vérité, c’est que la majorité
d’entre vous a été empêchée
de vivre ces expériences fondatrices
et formatrices dans ce moment-là.
Donc il faut le dire et il ne faut pas
culpabiliser d’en avoir souffert.
Une fois qu’on a fait ce constat,
on essaie de trouver des perspectives.
Je donne juste mon point de vue.
Vous pouvez penser : « Que fout-il là ?
Il ferait mieux de réciter chez lui. »
Mais on me donne la parole.
Comment essayer de croire qu’il y
a une lumière au bout de ce tunnel ?
Je vais partager
une expérience personnelle.
Pas du tout pour être larmoyant, mais...
parce que c’est
une expérience personnelle.
L’an dernier, j’ai fait
une grave dépression nerveuse.
Je n’étais pas étudiant,
mais ça m’est tombé dessus.
Je n’avais plus envie de rien ;
je n’avais plus de perspectives ;
mon temps était perdu.
Je me disais que je n’allais plus
rien faire dans ma vie.
Aujourd’hui, j’en suis sorti,
bien heureusement.
Quand je me lève le matin,
j’ai dix idées par jour,
j’ai un appétit de vie
que je n’ai jamais eu.
Surtout, j’ai l’impression
d’avoir gagné dix ans de ma vie.
Tout ça pour dire  - et on le sait depuis
Einstein - que le temps est relatif.
Le temps que vous croyez, peut-être,
perdre ou avoir perdu,
Peut être que vous allez le reconquérir
de manière extrêmement forte
parce que vous allez avoir plus d’envie,
plus d’enthousiasme, plus d’appétit.
Rien ne se passe comme prévu,
ni vos études, ni vos voyages,
ni vos déplacements, ni votre vie sociale,
mais peut-être que ces contraintes
sont fécondes de choses positives.
Par exemple, dans toutes mes rencontres,
la première image que j’ai, c’est :
« Mais ces gens-là sont héroïques ! »
J’ai souvent entendu :
« Je suis en train de décrocher. »
« Tu es surtout en train de t’accrocher.
Et dans des situations compliquées. »
L’année dernière, j’ai essayé de faire
des lectures avec des comédiens,
des répétitions sur Zoom.
J’ai arrêté ; impossible de me concentrer.
Vous, vous avez passé une année à suivre
des trucs à distance, plus ou moins bien,
mais vous vous êtes accrochés.
Je reviens à ma dépression deux secondes.
Aujourd'hui, j'ai l'impression que je peux
gravir n'importe quelle montagne,
et ça ne me demande pas d’effort,
alors que l’année dernière,
il y a des moments où je n’arrivais pas
à lacer mes chaussures.
Les efforts que je faisais pour des
gestes complètement banals et quotidiens
comme me lever ou faire
un petit déjeuner à mes enfants,
verser des Chocapic dans le bol,
là, j’étais vraiment héroïque.
Je pense que vous êtes des héros
et que le jour où la chape de plomb
qui est sur vous en ce moment va partir,
vous allez vous envoler,
un peu comme un boxeur
qui se serait entraîné avec des poids
lestés sur les poignets ou les chevilles.
Il y a un an, je ne me serais
jamais imaginé être là
à vivre mon rêve
de déclamer du Shakespeare.
Et encore, ça aurait pu être pire
car j’aurais pu vouloir assouvir mon
autre rêve : chanter du Dalida en public.
(en chantant)
« Moi, je vis d’amour et de risque.
Quand ça va pas, je tourne le disque,
je vais, je viens.
J’ai appris à vivre comme si
j’étais libre et en équilibre.
Moi, je vis d'amour et de rires.
Je fais comme s’il n’y avait rien à dire.
J’ai tout le temps d’écrire mes mémoires,
d'écrire mon histoire à l'encre bleue.
Laissez-moi danser,
laissez-moi,
laissez-moi danser, chanter,
en liberté tout l’été.
Laissez-moi danser,
laissez-moi aller jusqu’au bout du rêve. »
(en parlant) Je suis allé
au bout de mon rêve.
Pour sortir du ridicule de la situation,
évidemment, je vais faire appel
à mon ami Friedrich Nietzsche.
Je n’arrive jamais à le dire,
donc je vais l’appeler Frédo -
Frédo Nietzsche -
qui nous dit qu’il y a autant de sagesse
dans le plaisir que dans la douleur.
Et ça, c'est vachement bien
quand on est ridicule.
Deux choses sur la chanson de Dalida.
Premièrement, ne prenez pas au pied de la
lettre les paroles de la seconde strophe -
« J’ai le temps d’écrire mon mémoire » -
parce que là, vos études
vont être vraiment foirées.
Deuxièmement, malgré tout le faste
et l’éclat de sa vie,
Dalida, elle aussi, a été confrontée
à la question d’Hamlet :
« To be that is the question ».
Elle y a d’ailleurs répondu de manière
définitive et dramatique en mai 87 :
« L’abysse est en permanence
à côté de nous. »
Je crois que c’est à cause, ou grâce,
à mon ami Frédo Nietzsche
que je me sens concerné,
parce que, comme lui, je pense
que la vie est une tragédie.
Nous sommes sur un bateau qui coule,
mais il y a plusieurs attitudes.
Soit on se laisse aller, on se laisse
couler, soit on écope le bateau.
Et quand on écope,
la vie est plutôt chouette
parce qu’elle est portée
par l’énergie du sens.
On trouvera toujours des gens qui n’iront
pas bien, qui se laisseront couler.
Mais on a besoin de forces vives
qui écopent le bateau,
et vous êtes ces forces vives.
Je pense qu’il faut vous préserver un peu
et faire un peu attention à vous,
parce que si vous, vous n’avez pas
envie d’écoper le bateau,
on est vraiment tous dans la merde.
C’est un peu égoïste comme point de vue.
Là, vous vous retrouvez un peu
dans la situation d’Hamlet :
vous devez entrer
dans un monde imparfait, corrompu.
Vous avez un gros atout,
c’est votre capacité d’enthousiasme,
d’indignation, de colère.
Mais deux gros écueils
se présentent à vous
qui peuvent vous attirer
vers l’attentisme,
le radicalisme ou, pire, le nihilisme.
Ces deux gros écueils,
le premier, c’est
la référence à l’âge d’or.
Pour moi, l'âge d'or n'existe pas.
Les gens qui disent : « Les années 80,
c’était la fête du slip. »
Moi, j'y étais dans les années 80.
Oui, je suis vieux.
Je peux vous trouver cent exemples
qui n’étaient pas l’âge d’or.
Dans les milieux gays, à Londres
ou à San Francisco, au début du sida,
ce n’était pas l’âge d’or.
En Amérique centrale dans la guerre
des contras financée par la cocaïne,
ce n’était pas l’âge d’or.
Si vous étiez victime de la violence
politique en Europe de l’Ouest,
ce n’était pas l’âge d’or.
L'âge d'or, c'est une mémoire sélective.
L’autre écueil,
c’est l’attente du grand soir.
Moi, je travaille dans un milieu,
le théâtre, le cinéma,
où on est toujours en attente
de ce grand soir, de ce grand moment,
de ce grand examen qui va montrer
à tout le monde qu’on existe.
Moi, en ce moment, à cause du Covid,
j’ai un film bloqué, qui doit montrer
à tous que je suis le nouveau Brad Pitt
et une pièce de théâtre, une adaptation
du Capitaine Fracasse que j’ai faite,
bloquée depuis octobre, qui doit montrer
que je suis le nouveau Steven Spielberg.
Est-ce que ma vie est ratée
parce que c’est bloqué ?
Non, parce que depuis que j'ai décidé que
mon unité de mesure de ma satisfaction
n’était pas le prestige
supposé de mes projets,
mais plutôt la composition de ma journée
où j’accepte qu’il y ait 40% de chienlit
comme tout le monde,
mais où j’exige qu’il y ait
60% de choses stimulantes.
Du coup, ma vie a changé.
Je n'attends plus le grand soir.
Je ne cherche plus le Graal - désolé.
Non, j’essaye d’aligner
les journées stimulantes
et je sais qu’à la fin,
il y aura quelque chose de satisfaisant.
Donc, si vous enlevez les freins
que sont la référence à l’âge d’or
et l’attente du grand soir,
on a besoin que vous vous empariez
du monde dans toute son imperfection,
que vous ayez l'envie et l'ambition
d'améliorer les choses.
C’est gigantesque, améliorer les choses,
vraiment gigantesque.
Le monde est corrompu.
On ne peut pas le rendre parfait,
mais on peut l'améliorer.
La vie est une tragédie.
On n’en sort pas indemne,
mais elle n’exclut
ni la joie, ni le rire, ni l’humour.
« To be that is the question. »
L’existence est remplie
de choses exaltantes à vivre
que ni l’époque ni le Covid
ne pourront empêcher.
Améliorez la situation.
Les grandes révolutions sont
silencieuses - améliorez la situation.
On lutte contre des forces
gigantesques - améliorez la situation.
Rien ne se passe comme prévu -
améliorez la situation.
Nous sommes là et il faut
être ouvert à l’inattendu.
Un auteur anglais connu fait
l’éloge de la sérendipité,
cette faculté à trouver
par hasard et sagacité
des choses qu’on ne cherchait pas.
« Ne passe pas ta vie
à haïr et à avoir peur, »
dit Stendhal dans la préface
de « Lucien Leuwen ».
« Le bonheur, c’est l’aptitude
prompte et juste
à répondre à l’appel des circonstances, »
disait mon grand-père Pierre.
Il y a plein de phrases mantras laissées
par des gens stimulants, inspirants,
qui ont cherché à répondre
aux équations fondamentales humaines
qui ne se résolvent jamais.
Ce sont les mêmes depuis 3 000 ans.
En gros, c’est : d’où on vient ?
Où on va ? Qu’est-ce qu’on fout là ?
Est-ce qu’on laisse empirer les choses
ou on essaye d’améliorer la situation ?
C’est pour ça que j’aime le théâtre
classique car ça pose ces questions-là.
Et l’époque a changé.
La donne technologique a changé .
Mais votre génération
doit s’emparer de ces questions
et tenter d’y répondre à sa manière.
« Readiness is all. »
Hamlet, Acte 5, Scène 2.
L'important, c'est d'être prêt.
On n’est jamais prêt.
Nous n'avons pas le mode d'emploi.
Il faut se jeter à l'eau.
Et comme le dit mon ami Frédo,
il faut porter en soi un peu de chaos
pour mettre au monde une étoile qui danse.
Je voulais vous remercier de m’avoir
écouté aujourd’hui avec bienveillance
mélanger Dalida, Nietzsche et Shakespeare.
Et de manière complètement inattendue,
grâce à vous, je viens de passer
une journée à 100%
de satisfaction et de stimulation,
Je vous en remercie.
Ça a vraiment de la valeur.
« To be is not the question. »,
Jean-Christophe Hembert, Acte 2, scène 1.
(Applaudissements)